there aren't many impersonations that I
listen to myself do and go oh that's a
good one you know like a lot of people
like like I think Frank Caliendo is like
the greatest impersonator of all time
he's the best it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous and he's got a record button
and a broadcast ability that nobody has
I I really TR there's he's cracked
impersonations that I'm like
how is he how does he find he's got such
an ear but then he's got all the other
tools uh
I remember actually
my last season of Mad TV was also his
first season he comes up to me when I
met him and we're just up there in the
writer's offices and he goes hey nice to
meet you and he goes Louie Anderson
because I was doing a Louie on the show
and he goes Louie Anderson I go yeah he
goes hey you're doing it wrong I was
like oh am I Junior you know and he goes
he goes yeah you know because you do
this but you got to throw it up here or
sometimes I was like oh my God can I use
that of course and then we became you
know we became Fast Friends John Madden
is amazing it's just it's ridiculous
he really really embodies the person and
sometimes not even with a caricature
it's like it becomes the person so
strange totally